i'm inspired by you know life and all  sorts of things you can say something  right now and what inspired me to write  a song or something to happen you know  most kings just happened to be inspired  by basquiat drawing you know the drawing  he had most young kings get their head  cut off on the bottom and i looked at  that and i was like it's powerful  you know just the statement in itself  you know lends itself for a song  song starts inspired by basquiat my  chariots on fire everybody took shots  hit my body up i'm tired and then it's  just they build me up to break me down  to build me up again they're like oh we  need you back so we could kill you once  again you know it's like this thing  that's love  hate the thing that the world has with  success period